members of the public continue to pay
tribute this morning and pay their
respects to the late congressman john
lewis
as he lies in state at the u.s capitol
because of the pandemic lewis casket
sits just outside the capitol building
yesterday a hearse carrying his body
made one last trip
around washington d.c before fellow
lawmakers paid tribute
at a service in the rotunda nancy cordes
is on capitol hill with more on what
lawmakers had to say
about congressman lewis
good morning jerica john lewis will lie
in state
all day today there at the top of the
east front steps of the capitol where
you see those flowers and then
down at the bottom of the steps you can
see the ropes that have been laid out
for the public to walk by
in a socially distanced way a unique
outdoor approach to lying in state
at a time when the capitol building is
closed to visitors
thousands of grateful americans braved a
dc heat wave
to bid farewell to a civil rights giant
overnight the whole world just changed
and
it all started with him i'm sitting on
the great shoulders of people like that
they lost their life for us to have a
better life
[Music]
john lewis served in congress for 33
years
a close colleague of house speaker nancy
pelosi he blew
one last kiss goodbye we knew that he
always worked on the side of the angels
and now we know that he is with them
senate majority leader mitch mcconnell
called the one
time freedom rider a peacemaker history
only bent toward what's right because
people like john paid the price
to help bend it i won't be going no
president trump did not attend the
ceremony
but vice president mike pence came later
to pay his respects
as did former vice president joe biden
before arriving at the capitol the
hearse carrying lewis casket
took a final journey through washington
passed the memorial to his mentor
martin luther king jr and the lincoln
memorial
where lewis was the youngest speaker at
the 1963
march on washington we do not want our
freedom gradually
but we want to be free now the motorcade
also drove through black lives matter
plaza
[Music]
near the white house where lewis stood
in solidarity with the movement's next
generation just last
month his final public appearance i
wanted to show them a part of history
in line at the capitol we met kathy
ellsworth and her daughters
almost the day of his death he had been
doing things trying to get getting
involved
getting in good trouble and that's just
so inspiring to me
echoing lewis's own words which echoed
through the capitol
on monday you must find a way to get in
trouble
good trevor necessary travel
tomorrow lewis's body will be flown to
atlanta where he will lie
in state at the georgia state capitol
then
on thursday six days of public
ceremonies will come to an end with a
service
at the historic ebenezer baptist church
in atlanta
gail nancy that overhead shot looking at
the casket
is one of the most beautiful things i've
seen and how many people can we say
we're beloved on both sides of the aisle
not too many thank you very much nancy
cordes
always good to see you